ce qui m'arrive exprime un message que
je dois décrypter cette phrase de pierre
rabhi m'a frappé en plein coeur un a
rappelé merveilleuse histoire d'amour
qui a commencé il ya trois ans
pratiquement jour pour jour je m'appelle
caroline
je suis né au cambodge dans une famille
de neuf enfants de 75 à 79
j'ai vécu sous le régime khmer rouge en
1981 je suis arrivé en france avec une
partie de ma famille j'avais 9 ans
à 43 ans je suis marié j'ai deux
merveilleuses fille qui travaille dans
une grande entreprise française
je me sens bien intégré et en cohérence
avec moi même tout va bien
une nuit de janvier 2012
vers 3 heures du matin mais deux grands
frères qui ont disparu sous le régime
khmer rouge depuis 35 ans apparaissent
en grève ils me demandent sort nous de
la pénombre sort nos de la paix nommé à
partir de ce jour je commence à me
réveiller toutes les nuits à l'heure de
leurs appels et à tourner en rond dans
la maison inutile de vous dire que dans
ces moments là je suis partagé entre mon
rationalisme après tout je suis
originaire qualité et la certitude
d'avoir quelque chose à faire pour mes
frères mais l'idée d'investir des
missions sacré au nom de ma famille
voire de mon peuple nous semble
irréaliste irréalisable et le surcroît
un peu prétentieuse haut alors que
j'hésite fortement entre ce récit
rationalisme qui me dit ce n'est qu'un
rêve et ma mission sacrée
je me réveille toutes les nuits
à la même heure et je me souviens de ce
rêve
quel rapport me direz vous avec le thème
de l'amour
je suis venu vous dire qu'au sein d'une
famille l'amour est plus fort que tout
même sans nouvelles de mes deux frères
depuis 35 ans en 2012
ils sont venus me dire qu'ils existaient
et qu'il existerait toujours ma
merveilleuse histoire d'amour commence à
partir d'ici et vous allez voir qu'elle
est jalonnée de coincer dans ce
extraordinaire avec plein de messages à
décrypter
coïncidence extraordinaire numéro un
un jour pendant les vacances de février
ma fille me demande de lui lire un livre
qu'elle a trouvé dans le grenier des
chez sa grand-mère de titres journal de
guerre de florence rey l'eau curieux
comme lecture d'histoires mais bon après
tout c'est un livre pour enfants
pourquoi pas c'est une correspondance
entre une petite fille et son grand
frère parti à la guerre pendant la
première guerre mondiale à la fin de
l'histoire le grand frère meurt je ne
sais pas ce qui m'a pris
et pour la première fois de ma vie je me
confirma fille que moi aussi j'ai deux
grands frères qui ont disparu pendant la
guerre ses frères personne ne sait s'ils
sont morts ou vivants car ils ont
disparu depuis très longtemps
puis je commence à raconter à ma fille
que mon grand frère l'aîné était
guérisseurs et il connaissait plein de
formules magiques intéresser un film
demande s'il avait une formule magique
pour se faire aimer d'un garçon elle est
amoureuse d'un garçon dans sa classe
mais à n'ose pas le dire je les dis non
seulement mon grand frère connaissez des
formules magiques de l'amour mais
également des formules magiques pour se
protéger des animaux de sauvages des
balles de guerre je venais de me
souvenir qu'à notre arrivée en france
mon père nous avait montré des formules
magiques que de mon grand frère dans les
lettres recouverte de face et des
lettres ils sont recouvertes à deux
formules magiques ne montera de toutes
sortes
après ses vacances
nous voilà chez mes parents à la
recherche de ces lettres et la personne
se souvient où elles sont vengés je ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé en moi j'ai
l'impression qu'ils voient sort de ma
bouche et 10 les lettres sont là je me
dirige vers un cadre photo posée sur la
table
j'ouvre le cadre des feuilles jaunies
apparaissent mon père cherche
fébrilement
s'il ya une formule magique de l'amour
en effet il y en a une
le texte indique qu'à chaque fois pour
la réussite
elle réveille l'amour
je demande à mon père de nous lire la
formule magique avec ma fille on essaye
de l'apprendre
elle est compliquée on abandonne anti
mafia ne pourra pas tester cette formule
magique de l'amour sont qu'un brin de
classe dont elle était amoureuse
coïncidence extraordinaire numéro 2 peu
de temps après avoir découvert ces
formules magiques un week-end je décide
de regarder des photos de famille
tranquillement chez moi je sors les
photos je tombe sur une qui est très
abîmé on m'a expliqué que cette photo a
été enterré pendant le régime khmer
rouge ans en effet pendant le régime
khmer rouge
les photos étaient considérés comme une
comme une épée de damoclès c'était comme
une épée de damoclès pouvons dénoncer
notre passé de nantis nous notre notre
niveau d'éducation est un riche ou être
intellectuel était une raison suffisante
pour les khmers rouges de nous éliminer
j'y retourne la photo est jolie
this is my fathers photos réf ceci est
la photo de mon père j'avais déjà lu
plusieurs fois cette phrase mais cette
fois ci le texte me parle
qui parmi les frères et soeurs a pu bien
écrire cela je mène mon enquête je
découvre que c'est mon autre frère
disparu qui a écrit ce texte en anglais
car c'est le seul dans la famille avoir
pris l'initiative d'apprendre l'anglais
alors que tous les autres frères et
soeurs apprenait le français si ce qui
m'arrive exprime un message que je dois
décrypter je dois vous avouer une chose
je n'ai aucune idée de ce message mais
je suis heureuse d'avoir retrouvé les
traces les empreintes laissées par mes
deux grands frères
voici les deux derniers portraits de mes
grands frères l'aîné
les guérisseurs celui qui connaissait
les formules magiques
sur la photo il a 18 ans l'autre frère
celui qui parlait anglais
sur la photo il a disons moi je suis la
septième de la fratrie de neuf enfants
j'avais six ans lorsqu'ils ont décidé de
s'évader des comptes des camps de
travail pour nos clients revenir
aujourd'hui je prends conscience que
depuis notre arrivée en france
nous avons tout fait pour oublier notre
passé pour nous fondre dans la masse
pour nous faire une place en france
notre pays d'accueil mais cela a un prix
pour paraphraser boris cyrulnik
c'était fort pour oublier le passé est
en réalité un déni qui a enquêté au fond
de notre âme une crypte où murmurent les
fonde les fantômes de nos frères au fond
de leurs crypte et à travers mon rêve
les frères sont venus me voir et m'ont
murmuré sort nous de la pénombre
répondre à leur appel est devenu mon
rêve le plus cher
voilà le message que j'ai décrypter à
partir de là pendant vis de moi lorsque
je me réveillais à l'heure de leur appel
au lieu de tourner en rond chez moi je
leur écrivait des lettres en opposant
deux questions quel souvenir neige de
mes deux frères mes propres souvenirs
parce qu'ils me sens rapportées par mai
prochain et puis puisqu'ils ont disparu
depuis si longtemps
si j'avais la possibilité de leur écrire
khaimej leur dire je les raconte comment
son est sorti après le régime khmer
rouge
pourquoi on est arrivé en thaïlande est
ce qu'on laisse ce que l'on est devenu
aujourd'hui en france
puis je décide de briser la loi du
silence qui règne au sein de ma famille
j'enquête mes frères se sont évadés de
leurs camps de travail sont venus au
village avant de fuir
ils ont donné des informations aux uns
et aux autres
et puis plus rien qui savait quoi sur
leur plan d'évasion et il y avait t-il
la moindre chance qu'ils aient pu
échapper aux khmers rouges j'ai constaté
que chacun avait une bride de l'histoire
mais le chagrin était telle que tout le
monde était bien d'accord sans jamais le
dire de ne pas en parler
ainsi en rassemblant tous ces morceaux
épars
je suis persuadé que mes frères qui se
sont évadés leur camp de travail en 1977
sont sans doute morts alors âgés de 17
et de vingt trois ans et qu'ils sont
quelque part là tous ces points
matérialise les charniers à ciel ouvert
découvert après le régime khmer rouge
pourquoi à ciel ouvert parce que les
cambodgiens sont le tradition bouddhiste
en est selon cette tradition lorsqu'une
personne est morte sans sépulture elle
verra son âme
condamné à errer pour l'éternité
les khmers rouges le savez très bien
c'était une de leurs façons d'éliminer
leurs victimes et de condamner à une
souffrance éternelle les survivants je
n'ai eu aucune éducation religieuse mais
mes parents eux ils ont grandi dans la
tradition bouddhiste
je me suis mise à leur place entre temps
je suis devenu mon maman à mon tour sans
savoir si mes frères sont morts ou
vivants ils ne pouvaient par an refermer
leurs blessures m'ont encore on imagine
encore âmes était onéreux
qu'est-ce que je dois décrypter
maintenant que j'ai toutes ces réponses
coïncidence extraordinaire numéro 3 un
jour après mes vacances d'été 2012 au
bureau j'entends y coller qui se met en
colère contre l'administration
mais monsieur un passeport c'était pour
passer les portes je sursaute
oui c'est ça le message à décrypter un
passeport pour passer les portes pour
permettre aux âmes de mes frères de ne
plus être en errance un passeport pour
revivre j'ai décidé de relier mes
lettres au format passeport
je demande à mon beau-frère artistes et
à ma fille d'illustrer son livre à
quatre mains
demain d'enfants et demain d'adultes
comme ces deux parties de moi même qui
voulait tant se réconcilier celle de mes
souvenirs si lointain celte la
nécessaire reconstitution et pour mon
cadeau de noël avec mon livre au format
passeport
j'aime autorise enfin retourner dans mon
pays le cambodge que je n'ai pas revu
depuis plus de trente ans mais ma
merveilleuse histoire d'amour ne
s'arrête pas là de retour en france je
propose à mes parents de faire une
cérémonie des morts au cambodge à la
pagode vague quoi pagode dans laquelle
mes deux frères ont reçu alors leurs
enseignements bouddhistes ans je suis
persuadé qu'une cérémonie aussi
symbolique soit elle pourrait permettre
aux armes de mes frères de passer les
portes de ne plus être en errance et
surtout permettre à mes parents de ne
plus souffrir en silence
mes parents
refuse d'aller au cambodge il accepte
toutefois que la cérémonie se fasse en
france nous avons fixé la date du 12 mai
2013 que la série se fasse à paris à la
pagode de vincennes
il l'a encore un événement
extraordinaire
un mois avant la cérémonie une messe à
me contacter j'ai une bonne nouvelle
tu sais quoi un de mes collègues il
reçoit chez lui son frère abonnés du
cambodge devine ce que se ferait à ce
que ce frère fait dans la vie il moines
bouddhistes en et devine de quel pagode
il est il et de la pagode fat coi grotte
dans laquelle j'aurais tant voulu faire
la cérémonie des morts au cambodge
alors j'ai dit à ma soeur demande lui
s'il est disponible le 12 mai mais au
fond de moi je connais déjà la réponse
12 mai 2013
nous avons célébré la cérémonie des
morts six mois béni par le moine de la
pagode fat coi en présence de ma famille
et de mon livre au format passeport
c'est par amour pour ma famille pour mes
frères que j'ai décrypter tous ces
messages
l'amour m'a permis de réaliser mes rêves
l'amour m'a autorisé à faire le deuil
l'amour m'a ouvert les portes
extraordinaire de la vie avec plein de
messages à décrypter
en cette veille de la saint-valentin ma
famille et moi vous offrons la formule
magique de l'amour que nous avons
héritée de nos grands noms grand frère
le guérisseur mettez votre main au
niveau du coeur
que vous ayez ou non une religion
l'essentiel c'est de donner ou de
recevoir l'amour en fermez vos yeux hui
fermez vos yeux
penser très fort à une personne qui vous
est chère à l'humanité toute entière
écoutez ressentez et accueillez potins
temps mais on sent qu'un barça est meta
name au portail à 114 sens là ça n'est
permis
vous pouvez ouvrir vos yeux